you hear me yes i can hear you can you
hear me
yes i have to wear these headphones you
look
because like you're in a prison cell
i know we can talk about that this is my
um this is my
anti-theft anti-break-in uh
guard i mean are we rolling ready so
make sure you look here
yeah i'll look there if i okay are we
rolling ben great
i mean anna hussion is here that is the
pronunciation
um i'm telling i don't know if i'm
telling you that but that's
how you pronounce it yeah let's just say
for all intents and purposes well i mean
for all intensive purposes
i don't care how people pronounce my
name it's kachion
is it katrian yeah
it's it's technically hachion because
it's an armenian name you don't say the
k but that sounds like you're like
choking on a pubic hair
you know that's exactly what it sounds
like it's like too plosive i don't like
it i've had to pick pubic hairs out of
my throat and it does feel
like i'm saying your last name you look
like you are in a prison cell you look
like you were a thought criminal
in a prison cell right now yeah i've
been i've i'm
in a um re-education camp for anti-biden
wrong thing this is like a mandated
thing that i
have to have i mean it's really ugly and
looks like [__]
but i have to have it in this building
why is it mandate so it's mandated that
you have to have like an anti-theft
bars on your windows yes yeah
but like only this window because this
is the one that opens up to the fire
escape so i have to deal with this
eyesore
you know i you know you used to be to
get a mortgage for your house
you would have sometimes you in certain
areas you would have to have bars
on your uh or or the the bars were a
problem like
sometimes the bank would be like we
don't want bars in the windows because
if this is true
if there's a fire you can't escape
through a window and continue to pay
your mortgage
you would just die and then the people
yeah the neighborhood the people in the
neighborhood were like no we need the
bars to keep people out it was like a
weird tension
that they had well i was very honored
that the idea that your mom and your
sister are aware of me or like my show
made me very happy
oh yeah no my sister is the one that um
put me on to your show and she's like a
huge fan and i think my mom
my mom is like way more advanced than i
am she knew like who fetty wap and like
walk a flock of flame were before i did
and so this is like what i have to deal
with um
but um basically my sister's like a
super fan she was like telling me about
how you called um
gavin newsom a wine merchant yes
recently which i
which i i have to push back a little on
that i think he's more like a wine
wrap like he's like one of those guys
that walks around with like the carry-on
luggage and by the way my father was
that my father was
a failed wine salesman which is uh
an amazing thing to fail at by the way a
truly amazing thing to not do well
uh yeah selling wine but yeah gavin
kevin newsom we called him an effete
wine merchant um yeah
but i i just i love the idea that i hope
that she listens to it like while
smoking cigarettes in like uh
brighton beach apartment that's not how
she does but i just in my head
i just want her no that's okay listen to
it like in brighton beach
in an apartment smoking cigarettes just
angry and kind of
like pacing back and forth cursing the
gods
no but so i my sister could conceivably
be smoking cigarettes now i think we all
quit as a family but um
it basically like you know this is like
a lot of you know a lot is on the line
here there's a lot of pressure because
um people people have been anticipating
this moment this like merger of like
irish and russian excellence yeah
like my you know um my i also wanted to
say hi
to my uh gay best friend dan algredo who
also put me on the show and
he put me onto your show and he's also
the reason that i know dasha
oh wow so yeah um
that's a dan allegretto for any deranged
fans
who might want to track him down and sex
murder him a
l just
i love the people that are overly
paranoid about
you know i was on club are you on
clubhouse you want to talk about
neoliberal
hell but i'm addicted to it you got to
get on clubhouse listen to what
clubhouse
is it's all the tech people all the
venture capitalists
all all the sales trainers
all the hucksters and gurus that sell
motivational speed um this is
i kid you not they are all on
clubhouse which is an app where we all
talk to each other
and you listen to all of these people
and they're all in their element
and uh i troll on clubhouse of course
like i make rooms like
you could start a room and like my rooms
are always like should i
pay for my son's surgery or buy a
bitcoin or
how do i become a cancer influencer can
i build a brand while i'm in prison
should women own bitcoin very popular
room uh i did the other night
should women be allowed legally to own
bitcoin and many people were
that was a real debate but you would
enjoy clubhouse because it's
whatever this stage of decline that we
are in as an empire it is
clubhouse is it it's the app for
the just complete and utter
i mean it's just zuckerberg's on it
every now and then he'll pop in
uh like big big tech guys will pop in
um it's weird but you've not got on it
at all
no i can't i can't do another i'm
already like such a twitter addict i
can't be on another social media
platform i'm like 35 years old it's
becoming undignified
like showing my like hits in a flank
mirror it's disgusting i'm a bad person
for doing that
um but yeah i don't know is my is my um
enemy chamath chamoth on clubhouse i bet
he is so
chamath is he on clubhouse
he's got to be on the clock with elon
yeah
i thought i was going to make a lot of
money in gamestop and amc and i lost
i really believed this is this is why
irish people should not be allowed to
use their own money
i literally should have to call someone
to get approval to make any purchases
and so is my failed one what'd you say
like a woman that succeeds
it's not it's not that you're irish it's
that you're gay we shouldn't
gays and women should not be allowed to
make economic decisions on their own
behalf we're like so incompetent that's
a very good point because i truly
believed and i'm not kidding you like
when the amc stock was going up i was
wearing aviator glasses
and i really truly believed that i had
figured something out
and that i was going to retire quit
comedy and become
something else and i lost 1800
and and then that's it but you
had said something on the portal with
eric weinstein who's you know i think he
likes me now he was mad at me yesterday
i think he's i think he's fine with me
now
um you said something really interesting
about like identity
being capital like we have this weird
society where identity
has become capital i wanted you to kind
of go into that because it is
very interesting now um that we've
ordered society in
in that way yeah
uh first i mean first of all i want to
say that you look like an
angel who went to heaven i don't mean
that in a nice way but the background is
really blurry is that intentional
oh it's just on the skype it we edit
everything in post
i'm edited out in post and they put in
an attractive
uh black woman to do the show so can you
give me like
bigger boobs yes we're going to give you
make them really huge i want
them i want them like on the resting on
the table we're going to give you a huge
tip we're going to take you out of a
cell and we're going to put a cigarette
back in your mouth how dare you
quit how dare you i have to
i have to i had to stop smoking cooking
and drinking
okay what do you mean define have to
um i have a i have i should probably
just come
i have um a sexually transmitted
infection called i'm like eight months
pregnant
so is that true yeah well
congratulations
i mean do people know that with with the
next big uh neoliberal novel no they
don't but i'm gonna
just come clean because everybody's
always speculating oh my god so you're
coming clean on the tim dillon show and
saying that you are pregnant
yeah like a typical woman i have to drum
up some
um suspense and like emotionally extort
people into you know i'm gonna play the
victim for the next six weeks
right my back hurts this is
unacceptable i really want to i want to
call you know i want to say i want to
walk around saying this is unacceptable
how do you plan to hold them accountable
you know rectify all that
i have like six weeks left is your do
you have a name picked out for the baby
um no not yet i'm going to call it
neoliberalism
or something stupid i don't know i
haven't thought about it i think
i i think it's like really a bad idea to
think you know the people are like very
precious about this kind of [__] and
they like think about it and they give
it some like weird like gay edwardian
name
just like i don't know kids should be
like seen and not heard they should
recede into the background be
saddled with like you know adult chores
i'm only doing this so i can have like
an
unpaid domestic server you know because
i don't want to pay
i need somebody to produce my podcast i
think that
the name my parents gave me they gave me
the name timmy because they go
let's give him a name where if he
is uh a fat [__] it will
fit so perfectly
that it'll because timmy is the name
that was the name of the [__]
growing up it was the name of the guy
that was always joked around about
like timmy so they gave me that uh which
i i truly appreciate had my name been
like justin i would have had a different
life
well you would have been like the class
rapist
that's true and not a homosexual
comedian that's a very good it's a good
name
it's like very um generic but um cute i
loved it tim's my
best friend's name that's nice okay yeah
you're my new best friend um so anyway
the what was the capital thing you said
i said identity as
capital it was it was very interesting
uh
that you guys were talking about i
forget how it came up
but it was basically like it's a
zero-sum game now
where if rachel dolezal is pretending to
be black she's taking an opportunity
away from a black woman if somebody
right yeah so it's it's strange
uh how do we get out of this dude i mean
is there a way out of this
because all the things that you talk
about whether it's class critique or
you know class consciousness solidarity
it all seems to be
completely evaporating into this
kind of hellscape of you know
very strange niceties
and pleasantries and fearful
uh exchanges that people have and
nothing's really getting done and
nobody's getting to the meat of any of
the issues
is there a way do you see a role
for people like yourself on the left to
kind of
you know bring about some new paradigm
where people can have real discussions
again
and make better things happen
um well i mean in like the immortal
words of my podcasting partner dash
chrysoba i think like socialism is over
um
i think we should leave it behind in
2020 it probably should have been over
in 2016 honestly
um the advice that i give anybody who
feels demoralized or is like despairing
is that you have to self-adjust
and just not engage with these people
just ignore them because
you know they are a very vulnerable
population of bullies but
that you know you have to just starve
them deprive them of attention you know
which
i think people should also do with me if
they hate me so much i
that advice is across the board but like
i don't know i mean that's the thing
on an individual level all this identity
stuff is
a zero-sum game like if rachel dolezal
decides to
identify as black which is a pretty
crazy but
generally harmless thing right that
means she's taking away
opportunities from like other people and
this can only exist in
in in like a scarcity like precarity
driven
society whether or not that's actually
real but we're talking about like this
concept
of like elite overproduction that
there's like a very
small number of seats at the table and
everybody is locked in a vicious game of
musical chairs
right but like you know
you have to like indulge me for a minute
i studied game theory in
um college which is a particularly like
shitty
and fake subset of economics which is a
shitty and fake social science
and you know people treat these things
as a zero-sum situation but it's really
like a prisoner's
dilemma everybody is locked in a
sub-optimal outcome together
when like the alternative is to mutually
acknowledge that
this is emotional terrorism and we
shouldn't be engaging in it
yeah well i mean i know you're a fan of
um
[Music]
a lot of i forget the philosopher name
but the culture of narcissism you'll
know more
you'll you'll flash yeah we don't have
to we don't have to use the words
neoliberalism or lash for the rest of
this podcast
well i don't i didn't even use the word
i don't even know who it is i just got
cliff notes my friend ida
tava coley if you want to stalk her is
such a massive fan
of red scare and she's a very attractive
woman
who has been uh spending the last eight
months of her life
following because she's not working so
she's just following the stimulus
and she's become incredibly educated
about like
the laws and and the ways and means
committee and like she's
so complicated they just want the check
her and her boyfriend whom i love but
they really just want that like they'll
tell me they'll go you know
900 billion sufficient we don't need the
tuba and i'm like
so but they love your show and they love
you and dasha and she told me that you
were a big fan of the culture narcissism
i got in trouble the other day when i
tweeted the aoc
kind of reminded me of trump they have
similar characteristics right they
overlap to a degree their politics are
different but
they there's something about her and
there's something about him maybe it's
how adept they both are at social media
or how they love centering themselves in
whatever narrative it is
it seems to be i i have ants like this
where like they they will make
um their husbands cancer about them it's
fascinating
yeah they will make their child's dwi
about them they will make uh anything
about them so i feel like trump and aoc
have sort of that similarities they they
effortlessly center themselves by the
way it's
they're very good at it and it doesn't
seem like they're trying which is really
impressive it just
it just naturally happens do you do you
find that
similar because i know you have some
issues with her is it part of uh
is it part of that as well where you
feel like there's just a little
narcissism there
that needs to be raised yeah i mean i
like my theory my working theory is that
we've moved from like lashes culture of
narcissism
or narcissistic society to the culture
of bpd or like bpd society and i think
like
you know this is extremely like
reductive and rudimentary but like
bpd is just female narcissism it's like
inverse narcissism
making it about you in passive
aggressive like backhanded ways and i
think like
um you know aoc is a master of this and
so does trump because he's really like
our first woman and our first jewish
president
like he has a very kind of feminine
vibe about him he's a yenta you know
he's like he's too much of a gossip and
like
a pog right i said this before to be
like a true authoritarian fascist
i actually my my hunch is that aoc and
the squad are far
more they're representative of a far
more like authoritarian personality type
but they are these women that like you
know i i mentioned to you who love to
talk about um holding people accountable
and like
um this is unacceptable how do you plan
to rectify this and i think aoc is a
totally trumpian formation
like she couldn't exist trump
they have the same posters mentality
right they have the same grasp of social
media
as you said i think her sense of uh
her sense of humor and her sense of
comedic timing is worse than his
but they're kind of cut from the same
cloth
yeah i mean she's nowhere near as funny
he's brilliantly funny
in a way that he doesn't know he's being
funny uh
which is often when when well i'm
obviously a comedian and like
i've seen a lot of people in the comedy
world that are incredibly unsuccessful
at the business of comedy but happen to
be very
funny people one of the reasons they're
unable to
uh put anything together is that they
don't know why they're funny
uh which is i think trump doesn't know
why he's funny
like he uh you know he understands the
roasting and the insults and things like
that but
it's really this kind of like you said
kind of a
uh gossipy quality almost like a drag
queen he's bigger
than he's very big it's gold hair
it's uh you know very you know kind of
big movements the way he moves the way
he talks it's there's a
melodious uh quality to the voice it's
it's kind of like jazz
uh it's like a jazz uh you know quartet
that's not quite hitting but it's just
you can't stop listening to it um he's
he's amazed i miss him as you know as
you know destructive as he's been
there's something about him that i got
used to very much like i was used to
cocaine for a decade
and when you get rid of it you really
have to find something else and this is
just not cutting it right
the impeachment trial is not cutting it
it's like you know doing suboxone after
you've just been doing
uh benzos for six years and you're like
this is not it i feel like we're all
sitting in a rehab
trying to watch the impeachment trial
we're like this isn't doing it and aoc
is not doing it and
nobody's doing it for us anymore and it
just feels like wherever you go
especially the media it feels like
they're just in the grips of like
it's like they're in first year sobriety
which is just
it's a very boring and place to be where
it's the first year you're
sober you're just kind of uncertain and
you're making mountains out of mole
hills but i mean
do you think they eventually adjust or
are they going to keep dialing things up
to 11. i mean nothing's going to be
trump though
um well i think they're going to ride
out the dog and pony show that is the
impeachment trial
right i mean i think that that's a
purely
like cynical functional uh decision
to proceed with the senate trial that
nobody wants or needs
it's like total i mean a it creates a
lot of make work
for these politicians who don't want to
do any real work and
who want to continue playing hot potato
with responsibility oppositing their own
liability accountability and passing it
on to the next guy kind of infinitely
um and also it like you know it
is great for the media cycle these
people i mean the media is like a bunch
of like disgruntled adolescents
um who you know daddy paid their
allowance and now that daddy's gone like
what are they gonna
do they hate him but like
yeah you quoted me once just saying like
people talk about journalists there's
like no journal there's like seven
journalists like then
everybody else is like just whatever a
culture commentator whatever you want to
call them but like
nobody's doing like the actual shoe
leather reporting and like putting
themselves at risk and taking these
major risks and
you know breaking they're not embedding
themselves
with anything you know these are you
know it's pretty
basic uh you know type of like you know
you know fear-mongering uh from
whichever side
uh and they just do it all on twitter i
mean everything can be done remotely now
everything is zoom
you know it's like a zoom yeah you know
it's like they're embedding themselves
into uh you know taylor lorenz who
writes for the new york times just
sits on clubhouse every night waiting
for one of us to say the word [__]
and i say it every two minutes and no
one cares because i'm not famous
but she's waiting for i'm more famous
than her but she just don't love all
yourself
i mean compared to her i mean whatever
she writes about mukbangs kidding taylor
we know you listen
uh but she's in the clubhouse rooms
waiting for like a ceo to just
say something misogynistic and then she
writes an article about it and it's like
that's not a journalist a journalist
should be someone who like
moves to dallas texas and writes about
the kennedy assassination for five years
doesn't finish a book and ends up
killing themselves
yeah yeah that's true and the only the
only person who
the only person i can think of now who
basically occupies that role is like
um michael tracy he's like the sexiest
people
people magazine sexiest man alive no
he's like the most hated guy on the
internet people really hate him
um there's like three journalists jim
greenwald and taibi that don't belong in
prison
right um the rest of them are like you
know they're they're professional
aggregators
they're bloggers or they're like you
know like i said this on my the last
episode of my pod
they're like basically stenographers for
liberal consensus yeah
well they could you know what it is you
know how you know it's not good because
you could easily take any of those
journalists and put them in the writers
room at saturday night live
and they'd fit in yeah it would be like
fine like they could easily just go in
and like write a sketch about putin
coming down the chimney
and like hooking up with trump or
whatever high-level satire that that
you know trillion dollar operation over
there is offering
sleep is so important especially for
your immune system
okay and you have a helix mattress and
it's amazing and i have one and everyone
loves them helix sleep has a quiz that
takes two minutes to complete matches
your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you everyone's unique
and helix knows that so they have
several different mattress models to
choose from they have soft medium and
firm mattresses
mattress is great for cooling you down
if you sleep hot even a helix plus
mattress for plus size folks so you get
as big as you want and helix has you
covered
okay i mean it's awesome you don't need
to take my word for it they were awarded
the number one best overall mattress
pick of 2020 by gq and wired magazine
go to helix.com tim dillon
t-i-m-d-i-l-l-o-n you take their
two-minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life helix is offering
up to 200 off all mattresses
and two free pillows for our listeners
at helixsleep.com
tim dillon helix sleep.com
t-i-m-d-i-l-l-o-n do it you're not gonna
regret it
you could try it out for 100 nights
risk-free if you don't like it they'll
pick it up but everybody loves it they
have a 10 year warranty
it's great this is the new mattress it's
cost effective
and it's the best and you'll have it for
a very long time manscaped is here to
provide you the best tools for your
grooming experience offering precision
engineered tools to your family jewels
the lawnmower 3.0 trimmer is the best
hygiene tool for the modern man because
of their ceramic blade and advanced skin
safe technology
your snags on your snowballs will be
reduced
the trimmer is also waterproof so you
can trim in the shower or jacuzzi
if you're a savage manscape performance
package is the best buy of 2021 i mean
this is one of those products we sell in
a show
if you're a guy you need it's it's the
best on the market it's better than
the norelco groom it's better than all
the other ones there's not much on the
market in this space manscaped is really
really good
they have uh all kinds of things they
have a nose hair trimmer they have
obviously the trimmer for your junk
um they have everything if your balls
are gross that you can deodorize them
it's just whatever you want here i mean
manscape is really what you need and
it's not only for men it's for women
with penises it's for women with balls
it's for
it's all it's for men who have hair but
have periods and are pregnant it's for
everyone it's for people who have a
gender that's really only understood
uh in another life form it doesn't
matter it's
not for men this is not it's not even
called manscaped
it's you know it should it's just you
know it's
escaped i won't even say manscaped
anymore because it defends me
i'm gonna say escaped um
they have a ton of they have a ton of
other amazing men's hygiene products on
their website
from disposable mats for your pubes to
foot deodorant i mean now it's starting
to get ridiculous huh
it's getting a little strange it was
getting a little strange but
i mean it's like how gross are people
you know but all right
whatever they have a ton of other
amazing men's products like
colon cleanse powder and you know it's
like what
you know it's like you know
you know and cream for your open wound
manscaped
are you disgusting in every potential
way
twenty percent off with free shipping
but the thing is good the act
the lawn mower is great that's the thing
that everyone uses twenty percent off
with free shipping by going to
manscape.com
tim d 20 off with free shipping by going
to manscape.com
tim d that's manscaped for making our
winter wieners look so
good what what do you like in culture
what what is what is good to you i mean
i know that
you're not a pop culture mainstream
person clearly
but what does it for you is there
anything out there that
you know do do you do a marxist critique
of the real housewives where
where do you live on some of the more
cultural
things i don't even know what marxism is
oh i bet that's not true
no i've never read marx i you know my
parents left the soviet union because
they were compelled to read marks in
school and they came here so i would
never have to read marx again
right that's why i'm going to leave
america because we're going to be
compelled to read chelsea handler
very soon so yeah just to give you an
idea of the
compelled to read like abraham candy or
whatever
rob and dean um what do i like in
culture god um
uh that's a good question i like adam
curtis
he has a new documentary series coming
out hyper normalization was great
that's great he has a new one um
but that you know that man speaks to me
on all levels like intellectual
aesthetic like conceptual
um and he has like a very kind of like
mischievous
um world view and that like he's a
classic gemini much like trump
kanye azalea banks all the great artists
of our time are gemini's my mother's a
gemini
right um so he has he
he has this kind of like uh what are you
by the way i'm an aquarius
okay i don't even know i don't know i
don't know what that
means i think it just means you're full
of [__] which i think is
a good a good description of me
i think it might mean that you're um uh
chaotic
yeah that's possible it's a water sign i
don't know what that means but i think
it just means that you're like
i think a lot of people in sales or
aquarius a lot of people in art or
people that talk for a living or
aquarius things like that yeah that
makes sense yeah yeah
yeah um no but
basically he has you know this wonderful
vision that is kind of
fairly bleak but also not miserable he's
not a miserable
yes and i like i i like those aspects of
culture that aren't like
that are that are serious but not
miserable you know and i like real i
mean i do like the real housewives
franchises because they basically
are you know an interesting kind of like
sociological view into like
gender dynamics and the best sort of
thing
if anyone wants to understand the
mortgage crisis i mean there's a lot of
great books obviously bethany mclean
wrote a book called all the devils are
here she's a reporter that broke the
enron story
but really other than her if you're not
going to read her entire book
the first season of the real housewives
of orange county is probably the best
uh depiction of the financial crisis
where literally
uh people that uh were i mean
not to be unkind but you know
developmentally disabled many of these
women
had owned three or four homes and many
of the men they were with again
had sports injuries neurological
problems autoimmune diseases
i mean people that truly could barely
get from their range over to their
doorstep without five pills
somehow we're running real estate
empires and someone somewhere had to say
this is going to
come crashing down and it did but
there's been no better depiction of that
uh crash culturally than uh gina kehoe
who was a fat realtor who used to be a
playboy bunny
and her brain-damaged husband matt who
used to conservative daughter yeah yeah
her conservatives are
her brain-damaged husband matt they're
trying to get the kid to play baseball
and she goes we bought three houses each
of the kids have a house and you go
oh this isn't gonna work and uh but that
culturally that was like spot on you say
socialism is dead so what's
next um i don't know fascism
yeah i mean perhaps tim i hate all these
labels i think they're all so
fake i know they are gay and fake
um you know i was like listening i
actually listened to
um the the episode you did with candace
owens right
yes and who by the way i am the and i've
never said this but since you said
you want to come out and say something
i'll say something i am the father of
her
child i'm the father of candace's child
i decided to father a child with her
that must be great for your career well
it was very
it was harder than i thought i mean i've
done it a few times with women i'm
i've had sex with women none of them
would say it was great but they were all
preceded by
five course dinners and carriage rides
to the park so i mean really
yeah that's the whole package you're not
a what's it called a gold star gay is
that
is that what it's called yes one who's
never gone you're a woman no there's
there's
several long island women who've you
know had the privilege of
being near me what up so
you listen what did you think about that
episode cause people got mad at me that
i didn't like
i don't know screaming her or something
i mean i don't know she she's really
cute and small i like her she she's
zippy
and peppy she reminds me of black poglia
you know she has this
i don't know if she's i don't want to
say she's camille pogba i think we might
have to slow down with that
but i do like the energy i do like she's
pepe
yeah i mean like in her and in her like
vibe and her general energy i
i think she she has like the same kind
of
um energy but i think like the thing
that she gets wrong and that a lot of
people on the right get wrong
fundamentally
is they talk about like radical leftism
and
this isn't radical leftism it's just
liberalism
like all the radical leftists are just
liberals right this is the extreme
this is the logical conclusion logical
extreme
of taking like the individual centric
human rights
based framework and bringing it to like
this extreme conclusion you have like
the um you know
whatever the war on gender the war on
the family like all of these
things that we didn't think would be a
thing
this is just you know i think it's very
tactical
also on on the part of
like the liberal establishment and a lot
of people on the right want to
want to see it as like a kind of radical
left
phenomenon and it's really not you know
i don't think there is any meaningful
socialism or leftism in the united
states of america
no there doesn't seem to be much and and
uh you know obviously they're all
these these things are all you know
unfortunate terms but
uh you know in terms of of the most
aggressively liberal people are also
very much careerists in a very boring
uh office they love office politics they
love
you know these meaningless awards they
give to each other they love committees
they love
nonsense there's something very sexless
and sad about that particular iteration
of liberalism that culture even though
they're hyper obsessed with sex and
sexual freedom no one seems like they're
having it it seems like a very strange
uh churlish kind of you know
you know hyper focused on career i mean
everybody's got the attitude of like
you know um somebody that wants to be
the ceo
of the public space that's what it feels
like everybody just wants to own
a certain you know a certain uh has
certain turf and this is where i stand
and just [__] you know sling my
half-baked ideas and uh as a comic
it's just watching comedians become this
has been
sort of sad because i knew a lot of
these people or
i had you know had limited interactions
with them but i had appreciated some of
their work and like
you know chelsea handler used to write
some really funny books about her [__]
and they were funny and you know
she used to write you know about uh
[__] herself and
whatever having sex with midgets or
whatever it was and
now it's she's doing documentaries about
white privilege and i feel like it's
just
it's just it's hard to see that
change i don't know what i don't know
what to do with that i don't know what
to do with jimmy kimmel saying that
the people trading gamestop stock are
russians
i don't know why he's doing that i don't
i don't know what it does for him i
don't i don't understand i mean some of
them probably are
well look i mean i think just like you
ignore it and you do your own
thing because i think there's enough of
like an extra institutional
um population of people
that they have you know like somebody
like joe rogan right
has way more influence than any of these
people and they know it which is why
they're always trying to like get him
branded as like a fascist or
a white supremacist or a transphobe or
whatever right um
but you know you know and and another
thing you know that that she said on
on your on that episode was like like
right that like
uh leftism is like a religious cult
for people who wake up in the morning
wanting to get outraged or some
at something who who make themselves
like deliberately unattractive like this
sort of thing
and and really what they're doing in her
mind was that they
they were sort of like um they wanna
they they wanna um i forgot how she put
it i
wrote it down somewhere i don't know if
i could she's she was basically she was
saying she enjoys her life
and that people want her to be enraged
and she goes to the grocery store and
she sees
oh what do they have in the meat aisle
and people are like mad at anchor by my
pancakes yeah yeah the pancakes right
and she said yeah their mission is to
undo
things that people historically never
had a problem with or
thought even to have a problem with and
you know
cs spot the lie like she's not wrong but
that's fundamentally even too charitable
because what they're really doing
i think is so much worse which is taking
credit for
fighting these kind of simpler battles
of the past
that have already been meaningfully
settled um
far in advance by by forces outside of
their control
mainly um economic forces and economic
processes you know so they want to take
credit for like
accelerating certain battles like the
battle you know like all this like
gender
uh discourse trans rights and stuff like
that
and basically those things have were
already kind of like
economically baked in the cake that
people would become
kind of less gender binary as women
enter the workforce
right you know what i'm saying right so
many of these forces
are like you said brilliantly out of uh
people's control they're not exactly
uh malleable uh they seem to be
sort of static forces that just shape
the culture in different ways
and that manifests in in you know
different ways some
some of those ways are incredibly
annoying some less so
you talked about me too you said
something very interesting that me too
was kind of going to be used
as the precursor for a lot of social
control
you know a lot of compliance you know
this idea that
uh we want you know people that are not
asking too many questions or complying
um and i'm sure people don't get a
little angry with you
uh for that stuff on twitter people get
a little angry for you
paglie always brings up the great point
that men and women would work separately
for hundreds of years you know for all
of history and like men and women
working together
all the time in the proximity they are
is a relatively new phenomenon
and some of the things that come up or
you know somewhat understandable
go into the me too as a precursor for
compliance i think that's a very
interesting concept
yeah i mean yeah i mean i guess the
trick
is that again like all of these things
are were already made kind of
economically and viable i think like my
gloss on
on me too is fairly kind of like a
cynical and
unforgiving i think like the kind of
tiny brain read was that it was a
justice movement the mid brain read was
that it was a revenge movement which by
the way the most
kind of intelligent sophisticated
advocates of me too acknowledged were
just getting
revenge on men and they were playing by
their rules
um the the third tier kind of large
brain take was that
this was a labor movement it was a
changing of the art of the guard they
were sweeping out the old guard and
replacing it with new blood
i.e women and minorities and then i you
know for me there's like this fourth
tier
um that's like past the galaxy brain
take that this is kind of a
psychologically motivated it's a
psychosexual movement
which i again i'm like doing my greatest
hits i've said this like a million times
but i
women think they're mad at men because
they're hostile and aggressive and
they're really mad at men because
they're
uh ineffectual and
indifferent right because men and women
um
you know for the same spots in the
workplace men now will view
lemon as economic and professional
rivals so there's this like
weird kind of psychosexual pulsion there
there is like me too does feel very
often like a provocation to men
right to take the baby which they won't
because you know
for for various reasons
demoralized and non-productive or
whatever um but i think
more than that my biggest fear with me
too had nothing to do with sex or gender
it had to do with the fact like right
away like you know
i i feel like i clocked it had to do
with the fact that
it was a kind of dry run a dress
rehearsal for the broader
erosion of due process that we're seeing
um right now across professional spheres
especially like
in tech and in media you know people
getting fired
dismissed like cancelled whatever that's
this sort of thing and i think like it
was very
again i don't know if it was like
conscious but it was very tactical
because
um me too is appealing for a host of
reasons mainly
because you cannot argue with a victim
or else you're an unreasonable monster
right
right you can't argue with like that
it's general
slogan of believe women because if you
problematize if you call into question
that slogan it must mean that you don't
believe women and then what kind of a
person are you
i just i also have a problem with who
society claims are victims
you know i quote tweeted david hogg
today because he's now coming up with a
new pillow
because the my pillow guy is you know i
don't know alt-right he's making an
alt-right pillow so david hogg's not
trying to make a progressive pillow
and i just don't yeah have you heard
about the david hogg the parkland kids
david hogg is
one of those crisis actors okay yeah
yeah no he is he's the
he's he's a mealy mouth he um
is making a progressive pillow but
here's the thing i don't think
any of these kids are victims i would
have loved
to be in a school shooting and survived
i don't know
i mean think about that to be in a
school
shooting and to have survived
are you a victim after you're a victim
during it but when you come
out the other side are you still a
victim this is the last week of our
youtube channel man
thank god we are in texas because we
this will be the last week
of our youtube channel um but that's a
great point
you can't argue with certain people um
are you gonna what kind of mom are you
gonna be are you gonna be a tiger mom
are you gonna be like a helicopter
parent
or you're just gonna let your kid wander
around the lower east side and figure it
out have you decided
um yeah i haven't really thought about
it
my my own parent i mean i think i'm just
gonna be more like a father figure than
a
mother figure i already know how my you
know finally for the first time in my
life i like know how my dad feels
because i look down and i can't see my
dick and it
feels like really awful and i'm just
like standing there dangling cold cuts
don't worry about it you get used to it
don't worry you get used to it
sometimes you just pull up the gut and
take a gander it's still there
it's still there i'm so excited that
you're having a baby
it's it's a pretty crazy and cool thing
that you are uh gonna be a mom that's
pretty awesome
yeah we have to um it's yeah it's it's
nice i mean it was like totally
unplanned and
whatever but like i think a lot
everybody i know who has any sort of
disposable income is having a baby
i read on twitter that actually birth
rates are still plummeting
um but literally everybody i know is
pregnant
yeah well there's nothing left to do no
i mean there's nothing left to do
all the all the battles have been fought
and lost it's time to have a kid
yeah yeah it's time to to
[__] suck and and take back the
culture everybody also that i know who's
pregnant is having a boy which is
very interesting because it's almost
like nature is finally healing itself
there's all these girls there's all
these girls you know
a couple years ago it seemed like
everybody was just having girls you know
yeah it's a good point there was a lot
of girls
and now they seem to be my my godson is
a male there's a lot of male children in
the world and
and we welcome them well i mean it's
going to suck because they're all
totally useless
you know and right the 10 or whatever
you can't turn trans you have to send to
the white supremacy or like domestic
terrorist glue factory
yes yes that's very true but my god son
is part filipino so we are gonna really
that's pretty cool he's he's half white
half filipino
um and uh we're excited about i'm i
would not have accepted a white godson
like a white baby i would have i'm very
happy he's half filipino
um because i do some wild stuff so for
him to be tied to me i want him to have
some type of
defense mechanism it's also boring this
stuff you know it's like
i go on clubhouse and everyone asks me
about political correctness and i just
want to learn about bitcoin
and scams and i want to know you know
that's all i want to
hear about i just want to hear about
palantir and what the [__] these people
do
and and they just answer like well what
about canceling and i'm like can you
plea can you
please you're building robots for the
cia and all you want to talk about is
cancel culture
yeah it's it's so boring
i know that's that's the thing that's
like very hard for me to accept because
i think we've all gotten very boring and
stale
you know yes like because everybody is
like obsessed with politics
yeah and canceling and stuff like that
and you know that's also like a weird
kind of psyop i think because also the
culture
you know it's like genius had this good
point about kind of the trump
administration it's not that
it's not just that um politics has
become entertainment it's that
entertainment has become politics which
has rendered it boring so people have
fled
into like the political arena and you
know i've said this before and i'll say
it again and i mean it in a very like
serious meaningful way when women and
young people start getting
invested in politics something is really
wrong with the culture
and i don't mean that in any like
misogynistic discriminatory way
but politics is boring i remember
growing up you know i used to
watch my dad and his friends get
together and yell at the tv and i was
like you know these guys are going to
give themselves like hernias and heart
attacks over this boring
[__] about like kosovo like who cares
right and now we're all
we're all in the same like pathetic boat
defeating the left which is like
also a fake and gay phenomenon that does
not exist right
it only exists it's it's like um open my
community yes
in new york city the left of this
country is 25 open mic comedians in
manhattan
in brooklyn that's literally what it is
yeah yeah
who have some sort of like humiliation
fetish or something it's all
psychosexual
it's like a sexual pathology i mean but
that's the fundamental
principle i think to remember about the
left and about all of its fringe
movements and like lifestyle battles is
that
um i think they're the their strategy
you know again consciously or not is
to be as maximally repulsive and
alienating as possible to engender the
maximally outraged
reaction and normies which by the way is
the only normal sane
rational reaction so that they can then
flip around and say like hey
look the society is oppressive and
patriarchal
so we need to in that more cultural
and social policies to make sure that
the
um things are equitable well it's so
funny
i live in austin texas yeah now and uh
i i've been living here three days and i
live outside of austin like 30 minutes
and i went to uh a a place to get my
haircut the other day and the woman was
like you're not bringing your liberal
politics down here from california are
you
and i'm like well number one look at me
like do i look like a threat of liberal
politics
but also like i'm like have you been to
austin i mean austin is run
by like lesbians with purple dreadlocks
throwing bricks
through windows like antifa is a
political party in
austin it's like austin's always been a
wild place like
austin is for people that have failed at
like nine different
you know uh artistic endeavors they've
had a failed band a failed sketch group
a failed improv group
they've been failed comedian like
they've gone through everything their
failed actor and now they're like
in austin and it's just like i love the
idea that people are like terrified
i'm like dude you've got [__] silicon
valley here which is going to
put chips in all of you immediately and
you've got
austin which is already a bastion of
like you know this kind of crazy
wild you know out there outside of the
mainstream thought
and all these people just they're like
terrified of of like
liberals coming into the state i'm like
dude silicon valley
is going to colonize you and they're
doing it already like it's going to
happen and i feel bad
because people are very sweet but i
don't think they know what's coming here
which is like going to be the boot
the boot is coming yeah i think people
think that they should be afraid of like
um you know people on on either side of
the spectrum they think they should be
afraid of like
leftists or all the alt-right and they
should all be scared of chamath and
silicon valley because you know
what is doing i want to know about your
mother
i want to know about you i'm down 1800.
um no i mean like okay like in my mind
he's like a placeholder like aoc
by the way people when i when i uh kind
of made fun of that guy you know
if gavin newsom is an effete wine
merchant chamath is like
a small time franchise owner on a mass
scale though
he's like monopolizing it um but like
you know he's a placeholder to me of the
new trend in
kind of like silicon valley just like
aoc is a placeholder for the new trend
in kind of establishment politics right
so i have no beef
with him personally i'm not like trying
to i don't have an axe to grind with him
um it was very funny though because
people were very celebratory of that
critique when i was like hey watch out
for this guy but they get very mad when
i say
the same thing about aoc probably
because she's a woman
um but yeah no i mean you have like this
total merger
it's hard to say like chicken or the egg
but you have this total
merger like that democratic politics in
silicon valley
right that's really that we saw play out
firsthand
in this last election and i mean you
must have encountered that time magazine
article that we certainly talked about
on our podcast
about um the brave men and women who are
not rigging the
election they're fortifying democracy
yeah i mean it would be great it would
be great if they did that like right
after kennedy's assassination
and they just wrote an article they were
like listen this wasn't a vast
conspiracy
this was interested parties working
together
to make some change happen that was
needed you know
uh yeah it was a it's a and then people
like you know gina carano was just fired
from marvel because she's like hey
there was election fraud which it
probably wasn't but maybe there was a
little but there probably wasn't a lot
you know michael tracy's like listen
these people aren't right about i don't
think they're right about i don't think
there was a ton of election in front
uh but gina carano just says hey i don't
trust
the mainstream narrative about the
election she's fired
and uh and then there's an article time
magazine basically being like
hey we are all working against you like
it's not your imagination
it is i my mother's a paranoid
schizophrenic the way i could explain
politics to anyone is that throughout my
teen years
i said my mother is a [__] lunatic
throughout my 20s i said my mother is a
[__] lunatic
and i like feel bad for her almost now
in my 30s i'm like my mother is a
[__] lunatic but i really have to
hear more of what she says because she's
right about 30
of what she says wait is your mom like
legit
paranoid schizophrenic yeah she's in a
mental institution paranoid
schizophrenic well all schizophrenics
are paranoid it's not like there's a
schizophrenic who's like but i trust
everyone
uh it's all uh paranoia and uh i have
just enough of that to be funny and
hopefully not too much more of it but
yeah
she's real mentally ill everything
though yeah not like
yeah there's a lot of comics that
pretend to be mentally ill which is very
sweet
uh you know there's a lot of people like
you know you know uh you know chris
catherine has a whole show about mental
illness but my mother's like never been
profiled by rolling stone you know
she's like legit mentally ill she didn't
diagnose herself on instagram
so you know it's like real mental
illness real like she'll tell us elvis
is her dad she thinks elvis might have
been her father
like real mental on this yeah not like i
get sad occasionally and
you know need to tweet about it she's
like legit cooked
no i know well my mother has never been
diagnosed with anything she's probably
gonna
kill me for saying this on a popular
podcast
with a video component but i think you
know my hunch with my mother too is that
she's probably schizotypal or something
like she's definitely
cluster a which is pretty rare for a
woman and as a result my sister and i
are
totally cluster c we we kind of like
avoided the the
cluster b like bpd train and were
completely
conventional conservative neurotics were
very boring and stable and dependable
because we grew up with a crazy mother
who by the way is like right all the
time about like politics
yes culture yes her reads on everything
that have nothing her reading on
everything that doesn't have to do with
her
personally is totally accurate
you know you need to be schizophrenic
maybe to see things clearly in the
climate that we're in
it's probably a great advantage yeah
i mean it reminds me of that artie lang
rd not already
um quote that the the only kind of sane
response to
an insane society is insanity well i'll
give you an actual artie land quote who
said to me
which is actually the same same idea
artie lang looked at me at a comedy club
once and he said you know
he goes i've been sober for six days but
the biggest problem is this business
only makes sense when you're on heroin
i mean yeah it's the same quote that's
incredible
they should get together that's the
synchronicity that's truly amazing
gabby makes so much sense if you have
car insurance and you think you're
getting ripped off but you don't know
you just go to gabby
it's so easy go to gabby.com gabi.com
tim dillon what gabby allows you to do
is
compare your current insurance quote
to a bunch of other companies
on average gabby customers can save 961
dollars
a year okay easy
this is how i got mine when i got my car
i did this to get my insurance we looked
at the insurance i currently had and
then the uh
the insurance that um i could get
i found out there was a massive uh
problem so um
you know that's what we did you know and
i think that would be nice to have a
little extra few extra dollars in your
pocket
and if they cannot find you savings like
they did for me they'll let you know so
you can relax knowing you have the best
rate out there and they'll never sell
your info
so no annoying spam or robo calls okay
so
you just get to compare your current car
insurance with 40 of the top insurance
providers it's easy
you know i have good insurance and i've
like totaled five cars
so it doesn't really matter like you can
have problems you can have
uh you know you've totaled cars you
could maybe you know
there's a remember there was a hundred
car wreck in where dallas hundred car
parks
were worth it hundred car pileup in uh
uh fort worth
that guy that started that he's gotta go
to gabby got to go to gabby and find out
which company
wants to buy a ticket for that train
ride
but that's why you got to be careful
traveling um
gabby customers saved
a year on 961.000 you know i mean it
just makes a lot of sense i've had how
many accidents have you had
i've had three three interesting i've
had like
five but i haven't stuck around for all
of them like
the ones that i've had are like i've got
like two that have
like are like they're like i
stain and then like with cops and we
exchange information right like a lot of
them i just went
you just walked away you gotta go
sometimes
i'm not saying to do that but i'm just
saying it's my experience
um it's not a bad idea to get an
accident to kind of just get out of
there
if it's a terrible car just yeah just
walk away leave
just leave but you got to go to gabby
go to gabby.com i'm telling you right
now slash tim dillon that's cabbie.com
tim dillon how many times do i have to
tell you to go to magicspoon.com tim
dillon how many times
how many times do i have to tell you to
go to magicspoon.com tim do you want to
grab a variety pack
and try it today okay
zero sugar 13 14 grams of protein four
net carbs in each serving
140 calories a serving keto friendly
gluten free grain free soy free
low carb gmo free
fruity flavor is great tastes exactly
like fruit loops you mix cocoa flavor
with the peanut butter it tastes like a
peanut butter cup
it tastes exactly like regular cereal
from your childhood but it is super
nutritious
it's delicious but super healthy cereal
that brings joy to your mornings
or afternoons or evenings because people
eat cereal in the evening and we forget
about those people because they're very
sad
and they're alone and their lives are
horrible but they eat
cereal in the evening alone by their
window and they pet their cat
and they just they just have fantasies
of aliens landing and ridding them from
this hellish existence
but as they sit there in the grips of a
depression that we can't even explain to
you
they often feel comforted by the peanut
butter and cocoa mixture
or the fruity flavor magicspoon.com tim
dillon grab a variety pack and try today
and be sure to use our promo code tim
dillon at checkout to save five dollars
guys if you don't use a promo code what
are we doing
t-i-m-d-i-l-l-o-n tim my my dad got the
dumb wallet and didn't use a promo code
it's like what an idiot
have your next delicious bowl of guilt
free cereal at magicspoon.com
timberland use a good tim dylan to save
five dollars off thank you what are you
doing the podcast everybody loves it a
lot of people dig it you and josh are
great
uh are you gonna ever are you gonna do
more live stuff when covet opens up will
you guys do some
will there be some live red scares will
they'll be you know like going into a
theater
a place like that doing it live is there
any thought to doing that
yeah i'm gonna get on stage and squirt
breast milk at the haters i'm gonna
attend bar i'll make white russians with
breast milk
um you could i don't know you tell me
you're you're going on tour right how
does that work
we can't all of our live shows are are
kind of like high
bossed right now yeah which is fine
honestly because i i don't want to like
roll around on stage
yeah i waited you know cases are going
down of coronavirus which i know you
can't bring up because people get angry
at you
people like heavily invested in them
never going down and there's a lot of
people i know that just love digital
life so much like i don't want to shake
a hand or look in someone's eye uh
thank you and i'm like okay uh but casey
we stopped our tour when cases were
going up i think we stopped it in what
october ben because like the club
started to
we were just like okay enough's enough
uh and now the cases are really kind of
going down
we're going back to some markets and
their distance to rooms or whatever but
it's like
you know it does seem to be this
imperfect reality where like there's not
going to be one day
where they just shoot a gun in the air
and go okay life's back it's like this
strange
kind of going out there and just you
know trying to figure out how to do it
safely and
people are gonna take the risks they
want to take i mean this isn't life
that's the thing like
sitting in a room for two years isn't
life and i know that
you know obviously no no one wants
anyone to die or get really physically
hurt or sick or
long-term sick but it's just this is
also for yourself
but yeah but like
well that's what i didn't say i didn't
want that i said no one wants that i was
talking when i say something nice i took
in a very abstract way
yeah it's good for the advertisers i go
no one and i mean blue chew doesn't want
anyone to get sick
um you know i mean betterhelp.com
doesn't want anyone to get sick or hurt
but i'm just like i gotta figure out how
to kind of live again
because i think that i'm getting we're
all getting too used to this
we're too used to this and the silicon
valley people love it and when i'm on
clubhouse every night a lot of them are
like this will never end we're gonna
have a pandemic every five years
you gotta use all of our apps to live uh
we're gonna be distanced you can't see
anyone can't see your friends we
consider that domestic terrorism
uh so just all everything everything you
say and do is gonna be moderated by us
and content moderation is going to be
the major focus here we're gonna curate
your entire life
every every uh thing you like you will
like
because we put it in front of you and it
just feels like an empty
life and i just i want to get back to
like the regular empty life i had before
this
yeah i want to i want to go back to like
uh doing
lines and bars and having like
unprotected sex with strangers
yes you can't really do that anymore um
no it yeah it sucks i i really like
think about like
it sucks because i enjoy it on some
level i think a lot of people
legitimately yes we don't enjoy it
but i'm reclusive and introverted and i
like to be alone
and like you know wear the same pants
for six months without taking them off
and like you start you start to see
yourself
become complacent i mean part of the
reason that i moved to new york and
started this podcast 10 years later
later was because i wanted to be
i want i wanted to explicitly not end up
as a weird like tin foil hat recluse
like my mother you know
and now the the conditions have been
accelerated to such a
degree that it's basically impossible
not to that's like what we're all
becoming
yeah there's a lot of um you know my
friend the kid who opens for me
dan said that uh there's a lot like you
see a lot of women like really kind of
leaning into this like i'm such like 26
year old women being like i'm such a
grandma
i'm a cat mom and like they're baking
bread and they're drinking wine they're
like just i'm a wine drunk
and it's like just very strange it's
like the female in cell
it's like the female version of the male
in cell whereas it's just like i've made
banana bread
and i'm drunk and kamal is my girl boss
and like
whatever like whatever personality type
that is and
yeah it is to me i just want to get out
there uh
and and and see the ruins of the country
you know the just
desolate nightmare hellscapes in which i
try to entertain people the long
stretches of highway where people
are just praying they get trafficked you
know they're hoping someone throws them
in a van
i mean truly i mean the uh yeah the the
places where people aspire to be in
pizzagate
uh i want to see that you know the
places where there's buffets and people
smoke cigarettes and
people are angry and they talk about
conspiracy theories after church and you
know
they come see my show because it's
really the only option in town and
you know it just feels like i want to
get back to that really it says chris
hedges book says america the farewell
tour
it's kind of i want to get back out
there and just kind of
do that what's your read on him he's
like a fun guy i love
he's usually right about stuff but he's
been writing the same article for like
40 years
and but he's so funny to me like i think
he's one of the funniest people
because me and my producer will just sit
and watch smoked cigarettes and watch
him
do these very solemn sermons and where
chris hedges will like take the stage at
a church and he'll be like
the issue we are here to discuss today
is death
our collective death now our physical
death is more imminent for some
than it is for others but we are talking
about the deaths of ecosystems
and it's just to me it's like the only
real comedy it's the only thing that
really makes me feel better
yeah it's um the only thing that kind of
like transcends the the self parody of
the trump administration which no one is
able to match
i don't know i i i remember reading
chris hedges when i was like 18
and feeling favorable about him but yeah
uh i can't say i have like a
particularly well-formed
we always want we always our dream is
that chris hedges is actually like
a closet hypebeast like a sneaker freak
like
he talks about the corporate oligarchy
but he loves like bay hoodies and
sneakers and he can't get enough of it
and he's just completely like deeply
shamed because he's also
like a christian and a minister and he's
deeply shamed
that he has just a shoe fetish and won't
stop he's just a sneaker head
and yet he still you know delivers these
eloquent speeches about you know the
corporate totalitarianism and the state
and
you know that's our that's our hope are
you
uh are you optim well you're you're
having a kid are you optimistic about
are things going to get more
fun do you think or because everything
now
seems like everything seems so [__]
dry
i mean i was driving on my producer
today i'm like this
seems like the it seems like the
country's like a
it's a store that was just it's closed
and everybody is just wandering around
looking for exit i mean it just
there's just something nothing fun about
the culture of the moment right now
i mean i think like uh the culture is
like what you make it
right i have no choice but to be
optimistic
right that's the great thing about
having a child that's why i should adopt
like a child
yeah you gotta adopt some like black or
asian kids
a russian one who's like i work with a
lot of like i work with a lot of
alcohol yeah i work with a lot of like
19 or 20 year old college students that
are in need of like
uh uh there's kind of like mentorship
and money for school books so i work
with a lot of them
usually you know kind of harder from
them swimmers swimmers
you know kind of athletic 19 20 year old
uh college youth that really want sort
of a father figure
so i'm doing that that's kind of an
informal foundation i've set up
uh for them sort of just kind of it's a
direct
because i do think there's young men do
need a father and jordan peterson is
really not cutting it
so i think they need more of like uh you
know kind of like a grizzly bear in
their life so i try to put myself there
as much as i can yeah jordan peterson i
mean that guy
that guy got a bad rap and i think he
was like unfairly maligned
in the media especially in the leftist
media who wrote like
endless think pieces about what a pee
pee poo poo he was or whatever
but um that guy really was like the
victim of
his own insights and
predictions yeah it's really sad it is
it is sad i'm doing his daughter's
podcast soon
uh i liked him he was a little wacky
like he would you know ever he lost me
when he started going into like you got
to you got to
fight the dragon and bring the gold back
to the village
i mean that [__] i started to go wait
what's what are you doing
he started at the end he started to
sound like gary vaynerchuk like he
started to sound like just an instagram
motivational speaker at the end
he's like you just need to you know you
have to fight john on the belly of the
whale i'm like what do you what
is happening like it was a little it
started to stray for me
uh it's where i i couldn't get into it
anymore i couldn't get into it but
a nice guy and i feel bad that he had
the drug thing and whatever and
he had an apple juice and almost died
and went to russia i mean i don't know
he has a wild story
i mean it's true i mean it's a kind of
crazy like fairy tale story of like the
guy who drank an apple juice
and woke up in russia very interesting
yeah it's funny that your jordan
peterson accent is like a
irish leprechaun accent
i really can't do any accent except have
you ever seen the show mob
wives yeah of course that's that's a
cultural product that i enjoy
i love drea de alvanzo she's albanian
kind of like ethnically adjacent i know
drina i've
i've spoken her a few times i i
interviewed someone on the show ramona
one of the other ones but the only
impression i could really do is a
character named big ang
uh i'm dating i'm dating a guy
who just got out of jail for murder and
he bought me a pomeranian
um so that's the only real impression i
can do
is begin i love began to rest in power
you know she
she's totally like um reminds me of like
a [__] from like a possalini or fellini
movie yes like i think people have this
like
the view that american it's that italian
americans have like their own culture
but if you actually travel to italy
and observe them in their natural
habitat it's the same thing wow
they're just like about 40 pounds
thinner so if you go to italy there's
people that have scarface posters on
their wall
and and like their room smells like
dracar noir
the second one yes not the first one
exactly but the fashion sense is similar
you know what i'm saying yeah
yeah it's very interesting i mean
they're a happy culture
i mean my culture is as tragic as yours
to be let's be really honest
you keep you keep um freezing i know you
keep freezing too i mean it's
it's silicon valley but my culture the
irish is as tragic as your culture
yeah i think i really love the irish
they're my favorite culture um my
hottest take is that irish
people are funnier than jewish people
that's true this is what
this is what my boyfriend is gonna like
divorce me for
um we're not even married but um yeah i
think they're funnier and i i say this
against my own people
um and i think it's because they lack
the kind of solipsistic neurotic
correct woe is the impulse but they are
i mean
i take that back because they're also
very much self-hating right
like irish excellence is mediocrity it's
really beaut
thunder is beautiful yeah i am one of
the top tier irish people
just to give you an idea i mean i do a
show from my room
i'm one of the better i'm like one of
the more successful irish people in
america
you know who's the other one rory
mcilroy the golfer looks like he got hit
in the face
with a golf club i mean god we are not
we're just not
lookers and that's just a reality like
we have a president right
we have nice faces who the one we killed
kennedy
no biden he's an eye oh stop is he no
one feels like he is
i mean no one feels like he is he's he's
clever
i mean the irish are famous we have like
nice faces and then just
everything about like our oh we have
nice features but then our
skin is so
horrible and repulsive and breaking out
in hives and everything it's it's
truly it's just an interesting physical
form to be in for a for
for an entire lifetime yeah i mean like
well
the thing i really love and appreciate
about the irish actually is not their
sense of humor but their sense of ethics
i think the irish are actually deeply
moral ethical people
they're morally driven people we're
actually too
we're not savvy enough to steal it's not
really morality it's just we're not
smart enough to do it because we're
we're we're such storytellers and we
love attention we can't like
shut up for five minutes to like shut up
and you distract the guy and i run to
the bank vault like
we'd be horrible at crime we became cops
because we'd be bad at crime but we
wanted to do crime
so the state let us do crime they give
us billy clubs and said just go beat
everyone up
uh we love politics because it's
[__] um
and that's another way we can do crime
special crime yeah
exactly like the italians were much
better yeah was being like unofficial
yeah yeah so irish people just became
like these strange
unfulfilled wards of the state and then
just our irish
are try we're tragic people so we're
great you know storytellers and poets
and novelists and playwrights and some
of us are funny and
but it's it's it's all coming out of
tragedy and
and the tragedy of having such a
beautiful sad country ireland
is just this beautiful country where
people just [__] in the street
yeah i mean that's russia too it's like
irish and russians are very much
alternate universe versions of each
other
russians are less funny um but
the same kind of legacy of like
permanent clouds and
uh alcoholism right that'll yes and like
the
inability to grapple with moral
ambiguity i always say like you know i
was thinking about like
um why i like love nick mullen so much
and it's not because he's funny which he
certainly is it's because
he's his sense of humor reveals a
profound sense of ethics i mean i don't
know he could be a total [__] but
he's not everything i've seen he has a
great he has a great
sense of ethics and justice yeah
100 a lot of people do a lot of us
do i don't know that i do or not i do
but i might go work with chamath i
haven't decided yet
you know like i haven't decided yet i
got to see where this clubhouse thing
takes me
yeah yeah i'm gonna neg that guy into
giving me a lot of money
i mean yeah i mean that's kind of the
thing where it's like
we we we're we're always we have this
fantasy where we're gonna be co-opted by
like tech billionaires
and you know but the reality is we're
just going to go out to lunch with them
and then they're going to ask us that
they would like to do stand-up comedy
and then me and my producer going to
kill ourselves
because once we find out the illuminati
just wants to do stand-up comedy we're
going to blow our brains out
because that will be the closed circle
of life like that will be it
that's what all i need to hear is peter
thiel go what's it like when you're up
there with the audience and i go
goodbye and just blow my [__] head
off
because that can't be all it is and if
that's all it is
if it's just narcissism right to the
bone then i don't know i gotta check out
of here
well no but that's tim that's the main
thing that i really hate about our
culture
not that it's woke or stifling but that
our elites are like undeserving of their
elite status they're no longer
aspirational you know
all of these guys who are like silicon
valley billionaires are like
leaking their like nutrition regimen and
what protein bars they eat and taking
shirtless selfies it's undignified
i leave that to hot girls on instagram
yeah i wrote a tumblr
uh and ben can you get my tumblr i just
want to read her line from this because
it's literally
something that i haven't written on
tumblr in years i just transferred all
my facebook statuses to a tumblr that's
when i thought
uh that was doing good work and comedy i
was like well now i've
i'm taking my facebook and expanding it
um but i i wrote about that like i i've
always been obsessed with like the old
guard rich
fifth avenue you know north shore of
long island
and you know the people now that are
feeling their shoes
are are so grotesque and repulsive and
it's just unfortunate
uh and like you said i had this line in
here which i thought was
which i i was still i'm i'm still
somewhat proud of
and uh and i was just like i i thought
about this and it's like
i was just amazed because i would drive
around these areas of long island like
sands point and
they all have these stone castles and
they were all very
you know intimidating and and all the
people were mysterious there was like a
mystery there
and and it's just been replaced by like
this odd
touchy feely kind of strange
emo behavior that is like so disgusting
i don't know if i can find it but it's
like i i i want the
evil back like i actually want those
people back
who are you know you know what you're
getting
you know i i mean there's nothing worse
than people that are like obvious yeah
right giving you advice on like low carb
diets while they're trying to like
you know pulverize you into the pavement
it would be nice to just
just stay in your castle and you know
just you know leave us be what are you
what is dasha going to get pregnant now
as well
um that's a good question she's like a
little bit younger than me so she has
she still has a few years there's a
movie coming out
does she i'm going to plug her movie
please go plug it right now
um it's called this are you looking up
this tomb raider i'm never gonna find it
i mean i'm gonna i'll try to get to it
i'm so mad at how little this tumbler
succeeded
go on 61st street um and
uh it's it's a lesbian
gorefest that's a based on the
um like episteme events and i have a
small camera i mean
it's another thing it's lesbians i can't
even get in there
for a read that's great the line was our
titans are now touchy feely twitter
types constantly apologizing for some of
discretion
to expose to be interesting too boring
to be evil
but that's the way i feel about them
it's just kind of like ugh
i want give me rockefeller give me
carnegie give me somebody
i know you know but so doc what's the
movie
what's the movie called that she's in um
it's called the scary of 61st street she
directed it and
and she and our friend madeline quinn uh
wrote it
how [__] awesome is that yeah it's
really cool that's her baby
that's a a kind of uh
um i think that that is going to come
it's coming out
in i want to say like in the spring so
well that's [__] awesome i'm just
gonna i'm gonna plug it in advance um
but um yeah no this is like certainly
true that's the thing it's like
i think this is like what hannah or rant
meant by like the banality of evil
right um everybody's like so kind of
like
banal undignified unworthy now and it's
again like i said this before and i'll
say it again but you know you should be
more suspicious of people who have like
a social mission or a social agenda then
you should be
of those that are motivated by naked
greed right yes especially in like the
investment and finance world there's no
reason that
finance and investment guys should be
talking about
like um social justice yeah it's crazy
it's crazy do you have anything else to
plug tell people where to find you we
really appreciate you coming on your
your uh everyone has always told me how
great you were and i just i
ignore i don't really i ignore most
women but i i
kept hearing your name and i appreciate
that that's what i like about you
but i kept hearing your name i like
realtors like
like big titted blonde like or brown
hair
just kind of vicious masculine real
estate women i don't
i don't know why but i like that's kind
of my thing so i just read about like
female realtors it's crazy where can
people find you because you are the best
and everybody loves you
thank you did i disappoint you guys no
not at all
i wish you weren't one to ten i wish you
were in the studio because obviously
everything's better in studio
but this is we're gonna edit it it's
gonna be good we'll edit a lot of the
right ben can we edit a lot of the
things you're going to work
you know edit out the parts where i look
desperate and lost because one of our
screens froze
where can you find me on twitter.com
unfortunately though i should probably
deactivate again um
uh and i don't know if i have anything
oh don't deactivate there's nothing
better than pushing a baby out and then
grabbing that phone
and going right back to it there's
nothing better than holding your child
and going giving it to your boyfriend
and going
back to business grabbing the phone and
just going
oh my god that's my worst fear no photos
but because i don't trust myself first
of all
you see how many photos i take of this
freaking cat by the way
i have i have i have treats i was trying
to lure the cat over
at any rate yeah you can find me on
twitter i have some stuff
also coming up on the horizon that is
not a baby
but i guess i'll talk about it later
thank you for having me
no well you are you're the best i'm very
excited that you chose to break the news
of your pregnancy and you really haven't
said anything before this podcast
no okay it's not like brand new shout
out remember brandon chop said he told
us the name of his son for the first
time and then he's
set on four other podcasts we're like
okay but no this is
i really appreciate that we're we're i'm
very excited for you and it's like
you're a real grown-up now you're like a
real adult i know
should i adopt a kid i don't know should
i i mean i don't i don't know
you want to adopt my kid you can have my
kid well it's
okay i mean yeah i mean i might like to
raise a woman too and make her a real
estate agent
a lesbian like if you're like a like a
bull dyke realtor
like that's what i'd want like a tough
realtor who was like
very just like like tweed jackets in the
northeast and like
sold mansions in greenwich and like kind
of like william f buckwheat
buckley with a [__] yeah that sounds fun
i mean yeah i love realtors and and
prostitutes and
uh some nurses though not all of them
yeah
you know a brassy woman with balls i
love it that's my favorite well anna
kochan yeah you are phenomenal i'd love
you to get out of jail
i mean new york's such a hell i mean i
love new york i'm a new yorker it made
me who i was but i mean
god it's just bleak over there yeah
it sucks right now and now there's all
this gay
and fake news about how we have to wear
two masks i mean
anyway what are we doing here i mean i'm
i'm
just in the middle of texas where i just
i just want to get bit by a rattlesnake
and die on the side of the road alone
you know i just want to sit on a porch
and smoke cigarettes and you know
talk to people i no longer have any
interest in hearing or seeing
yeah i mean you should do that
when's your are you coming to the east
coast for your touring schedule yeah
i'm doing baltimore i'm doing uh
pennsylvania i'm performing in a heated
dome in pennsylvania 2021.
uh i'm doing uh uh cleveland i'm doing
uh providence rhode island there's
nothing open in new york right now so
i'm not doing that
but i might go into new york for a day
or two because i'm supposed to do the
art garbage podcast which is really cool
i uh i might just pop into new york
really to eat at a restaurant more often
than not
to me new york city is really about
restaurants and and everything from
diners to
you know randazzo's clan bar over in
sheepshead bay where i would just sit
with old russians and eat
you know uh manhattan clam chowder
silently and
watch the snow you know i do miss that
about new york just kind of eating alone
which is really so um such a requirement
in new york
that you just go out and eat alone and i
love and i miss that because in texas or
l.a that's really not the case
but in new york just eating alone is so
okay and i just i missed that
i missed that i'm just going out to like
a nice restaurant by yourself
yeah that's a very kind of a male
activity to do i think if you do that
like in the south or the west people
think you're a liberal freak and a child
molester
exactly anyway we i mean please
stop on by to new york eat in one of
those weird inflatable tents
if you come at the end of march you can
have my baby and i can embark on my girl
bus career and get skinny again i hope
it ends with me raising your child and
you with trimath
yeah that would be great you know
all right adam thank you so much you're
the best we really appreciate it
thank you